hi guys is quinn here and as always if
you appreciate my content consider
hitting the like button it's the only
way the youtube algorithm really sees me
now in this video we're going to be
talking about the ending of dune
not the ending of the first one because
that's been discussed to death
but the ending of the saga
as a whole
because it doesn't end the way you might
necessarily think
in fact it gets pretty meta and pretty
trippy
now this is an ending that i thought
about probably more than any sci-fi
series that i've ever read and that's
probably because on the surface
this really isn't an actual ending
apparently another dune book was
intended so when i think about this
ending what i used to think about a lot
was
where was the story going
but at this point i read that final
chapter and i think
maybe i was thinking about it all wrong
maybe the fact that frank herbert never
put out the seventh book
is the point
now of course generally it is thought
that frank herbert had a seventh book
planned and that he was intending to put
out a seventh book but tragically died
but i think there are a few hints in
this last chapter that would suggest
that maybe this was the intended ending
for the dune saka
to explain this we've got to talk about
what doom is actually saying
the dune saga is about the evolution of
humanity it's about humans elevating
themselves while coexisting amongst each
other and preparing for the hostile
environment of the universe they inhabit
frank herbert saw humanity as it
currently exists now as kind of the
teenage phase of humanity and doom is
essentially how humankind grows up
specifically there is a direct critique
of bureaucracy and centralized
leadership now this is crucial frank
herbert makes it relatively clear what
aspects of government and politics and
human society that he's critiquing
but he's relatively vague on how we
should go about
fixing those problems in society now of
course there are clues and subtle hints
pointing at a type of system that frank
herbert would be partial to throughout
the book series but it's not exactly
cohesive he seems to be partial with
certain anarchist leaning ideologies see
the friman but he never drives the wedge
home and describes any particular system
that he thinks would be best in the way
that let's say ursula k le guin does in
her work specifically the dispossessed
where she's very clear and defining the
anarchist society
in fact this is what kind of
differentiates frank herbert from a lot
of other authors is that frank herbert
wants you to figure it out on your own
he doesn't want to tell you he wants you
to figure it out
and that is the main key when it comes
to the ending of the dune saga
all right so now let's talk about the
ending so chapter house doing which is a
book that not a lot of people have read
even a lot of dune fans have not read
chapter house dune so in chapter house
dune we are in the meat of the benny
jesuit conflict with their rival
sisterhood the honored matres aka the
honored mothers whose name is of course
reminiscent of the bini jesuit reverent
mothers
at the end of the book we see the
conflict more or less resolved
and then the curtain is pulled back so
to speak and we are officially
introduced to two characters
daniel and marty
and they appear as an old man and an old
woman and they've been kind of watching
the events
of the last several books in the dune
saga perhaps it's not really clear
how long they've been around
but they've definitely been watching for
quite some time
and they have
god like technology that's almost
incomprehensible indescribable and they
were intending to use this technology to
capture
certain protagonists and they were going
to take these protagonists they had an
entire planet picked out for them
apparently and they were going to use
this planet to test the abilities
of these protagonists
but daniel and marty aren't able to
because
the characters
escape from them they get out of their
hands the characters are no longer in
their hands
what we're seeing here in my opinion and
some other people have picked up on this
as well
is frank herbert and his wife beverly
inserting themselves into their story
because a lot of people aren't aware of
the fact that the doomed saga is
essentially a collaboration between
frank herbert and his wife
they inserted themselves into this story
and they allowed the characters to get
away from them
as a way of saying to the readers
now you figure it out
because it does seem like more and more
that the dune books were leading up to
the seventh book
this is the answer this is the structure
of existence where human beings can
exist indefinitely in the universe
that's what it seems like the seventh
book was leading up to that's what it
seems like frank herbert was gonna say
but of course frank herbert never
gives it away
he says i want you to think and that
theme of not being told the answer but
having to figure it out yourself is
something that runs its way throughout
the entire dune saga we see it over and
over and over again it's the very reason
that in the fourth book god emperor of
june that lato does not tell siona to
put on her face mask she has to figure
it out herself
she even says you could have warned me
and he responds
and increased your dependency and
there's also that quote in lato's
fantastic message to the benny desert
where he says with words
you can cry out in the chorus
why didn't someone warn me
but i did warn you
i warned you by example frank herbert is
saying here that the dune saga has
already told you everything you need to
know and it is up to you to think for
yourself and figure out the next step
he's not gonna give it to you
the dune saga is all about test
and we brushed this topic a little bit
on alt shift x's podcast which i was on
the other day link in the description
but the dune saga begins with the test
the tests paul atreides test obviously
and it ends with a test
this time it is our turn
the entire dune saga has been the lesson
and now it's time to see if we can
pass the test so that's just one
interpretation i'm not saying that frank
herbert definitely did not intend to
write a seventh book he definitely could
have left behind a bunch of notes for
what he
would have done
but
i also think that frank herbert could
have been giving himself an out here and
saying that if i don't do another book
this could suffice as an ending if you
really really think about it now i'm not
saying that anything on the surface
level is different to how i previously
interpreted it but thematically i think
that this particular thematic
interpretation is very consistent
let me know what you guys think about
this idea if you enjoy my content you
can follow me on twitter subscribe to me
on this channel make sure you hit the
like button thanks so much guys
[Music]
you